how does the director build strong
relationships with her actors
director builds strong relationships
with actors you know it's all about
trust it's
an actor is going to decide in the first
30 seconds of
meeting a director if this is somebody
they can work with
they've they've sized you up it's almost
like having a blind date
they size you up when you walk through
the door what can i get away with
what are they going to command for me
are they going to stretch me and make me
into something better or can i put this
in cruise control and just kind of ride
it out
and what i've found is i i like to
listen to an actor
um i like to let an actor know that i
i run a set that's very relaxed i i'm
not a yeller i
i trust i said if you're here it's
because i trust you now we just got to
get to the point where you trust me
so i let actors know that
you know what's important to me is i get
the movie that we need to make
give me what i need and i'll give you
what you want every time if you
show up prepared and you're able to give
me and the time allotted to do the scene
what i need i will give you what you
want
and i know nine times out of ten
what you want is going to be better than
what i need and i find when i tell and
that's true that's not lip service i
don't say that to every actor but you
know when i'm dealing with my leads and
people that i trust that have earned
that
i find that barrier comes down and they
start to get excited and realize that
this is a safe place
you know i i learned something very
interesting from martin sheen
when we were doing a film together 100
years ago he was telling the story when
he had a heart attack on apocalypse now
and he was being wheeled into surgery
and his dear wife jan
looked over him and said it's only an f
in movie martin
and he told that story but apocalypse
now is one of the most
known films in our history it's huge
and i never forgot that story
and i never forgot that
it's only a movie you know
relationships are forever there's 33 000
movies a year that are probably made
through sag
why is this one going to be any more
special than the next or less important
than the next it's only a movie
we're not curing cancer we're not curing
covid
what's most important is people feel
better after the experience than they
did coming into it for me
and i want my actors to feel respected i
want them to feel like they can grow
i want them to feel like they can
challenge me because i hope i become a
better filmmaker because of our
experience you know and
um i think if you go in
allowing an actor to stretch their legs
keep them reined in when you have to but
trust when you make a decision on an
actor that is who you have entrusted
that role
and that story to be told by through
their eyes and their vision
i think it's important to let an actor
feel like they
they can have the freedom to play and to
explore and experiment
and then as a as a director and an actor
i think you can find that middle ground
where
you're getting the story and the
performance that you need
as a filmmaker but as an actor and an
artist they're being able to
to fly in a way that they don't feel
stifled or congested
or condemned and i think if you can find
that balance
i mean you look at some of the great
relationships that some directors and
actors have i mean you can look at
spielberg and tom hanks
or zemeckis and tom hanks when they work
together on castaway and some of the
other films and
you you try to get 1 100th of that
greatness or that relationship and and i
find that
i i've never walked away working from a
never walked away working
with an actor regretting the experience
didn't matter who it was or what the
project was i've
never walked away from an actor
regretting it and i hope they feel the
same for me
do you think um most sets are as
stressful as apocalypse now was or or
what percentage i should say
i think i ever reached that point i
think a lot of sets are unnecessarily
stressful it's something i talk about in
my book i think
especially young filmmakers put so much
stress
and pressure they are making a movie
because god damn it it's getting into
sundance are our bust
and that is like the least thing you
should be worried about make a good
movie
learn and enjoy this experience you may
never do it again it's like
it's like they tell you and rudy you
know you may be putting on the football
uniform for the last time enjoy it live
in the moment and i
tell filmmakers that this could be your
one and only chance to tell a story as a
director before it fails and you have to
go sell stocks or
become an insurance salesman or whatever
it is that you could do
nothing wrong with that but being a
filmmaker is a dream
okay there's very few people who can
make a living at it so i always tell
people look this is this could be the
only time you're ever going to do it you
might as well enjoy it
and i think if you enjoy it and the
people around you
feel that you're enjoying it it's going
to be a much more pleasurable experience
when people are happy they deliver
better things
i find that people put unnecessary
stress on themselves because they
they just don't see it with the end in
mind
they're so worried about what they're
getting and i think that's the
importance of
being knowledgeable in editorial every
filmmaker before they want to
you know before they become a director
before they become a writer
i think they need to spend three to five
years in the edit bay fixing other
people's mistakes
because one reason i'm able to
maintain a good demeanor i know when i
make a film it's because
i know when i nail something how i'm
going to use it i know exactly how many
frames of it i'm going to use i know
exactly where in the story i'm going to
use it
and it just it's not arrogance it's just
confidence it's knowing the craft of
telling a story doesn't mean my movies
are great but
i look at something and i don't
overshoot i don't get a lot of takes i
don't need it
i trust my cameraman i trust my actors
and i trust myself
to tell the story and i think if if
people can just kind of
and it goes back to hiring the right
people people can just kind of take a
breath
and enjoy the moment and just realize
that we are so blessed to be able to do
this
i think they'd be pretty surprised with
the
the outcome that they get when they look
at the dailies i think they'd be
pleasantly surprised
and with apocalypse now weren't there
things just completely out of
copela's control that i mean what they
were going on with the
government at the time you know with
with those different locations there is
things happen there is always problems
on a film and as i as i try to stress
and we talked about earlier i over
pre-produce a film
so that way when something when a little
bit you know wheel comes off the wagon
or a lug nut gets loose
it's not a catastrophe i'll give you an
example we were doing our last film
i wrote a part or you know cj wrote a
part
with with my request for a specific
actor i was a big fan of i
fell in love with an actor on a show i
knew i could get to them
and i wrote a part for them and we made
a deal and this actor was going to be
part of the film
and long story short the day we showed
up to shoot i got a call from
her agent she said her father just died
she's got to jump on a plane and go to
detroit we're so sorry
just reschedule it she'll she'll be back
in five six days
rescheduled i said i wish i could it's
the only time
i'm here we work at a very quick pace
we got to figure this out i said i'm
going to go to you first you have
another actor you want to give me that
you feel can do the role
and he was funny he was oh my god i
can't believe you're not freaking out i
said no i'm concerned about the actor
and her well-being for her dad
i will reach out to her but i said i
want you to think about somebody you
have on your roster you've got you've
got 20 minutes before i start making
calls to other agents and he called me
he said i've got somebody
and i don't want to name names but it
ended up being a pretty damn good cat
and um it's it's about not losing it
it's about just taking a breath and
realizing it's only a movie it'll all
figure itself out
that's what we have to do you know the
only way to make it work you know our
biggest day of shooting on breakeven i
had nine cameras i had an entire cast
and half my crew get food poisoning at
the hotel from bad ice
where our call time that day was 8 am
we're supposed to start rolling cameras
at 10.
i think people started showing up around
12 30 or 1 the ones that did show up and
didn't go to the hospital and i didn't
start shooting my biggest day of the
film
until 1 30 2 o'clock and
i i had a choice i could yell and scream
i could
throw a fit um i could kick a seagull
was it the ocean and i realized getting
upset wasn't going to make
my casting crew better it was only going
to
let my existing cast and crew realized i
was out of control
and i decided to just deal with what we
got let's make it work
and you know it worked of course when i
watched the scene back i wish i would
have had more time
of course when i watched a scene back i
wish i would have gotten more angles
but i'm pleased with what we got and
because of my knowledge
in post i knew exactly how we had to do
this now with a
fraction of the time and it just comes
from
confidence in telling a story being
understanding the editorial process so
those are things that are out of your
control you know
shot another scene and there was a
construction you know we went and
scouted it got a permit
had a whole scene and it turned out they
started building a house or demolishing
a house right across from it
you know what do you do that's out of
your control and it's a very dialogue
heavy scene that you know you're not
going to loot
so you you find the nicest person and
the most reasonable person on your crew
to go over and talk to the foreman
and work out and say hey we're here for
two hours can we do this can we
we go you go we go you go and they
worked with us
you know this is what it's about what
did gary bucy teach you about being a
director
gary busey taught me so much about being
a director the first
narrative i ever directed starred gary
busey
talk about you know baptism under fire
gary is unbelievably talented gary is
hebrew
you know he brought 40 years to the
table i mean there's a guy had done you
know 75 movies when i worked with him at
this point here i was directing my first
i of course produced and written a lot
of stuff and never directed before
so um i learned how to
take a punch and i don't mean physically
i mean i learned how to take a punch i
learned how to
to improvise i learned how to be strong
because when you work with an actor like
gary abuse you're the late dennis hopper
those guys are constantly testing you
they they get
more pleasure out of trying to break you
to find out how tough you
are and they're going to decide what
they're going to give you with your
toughness
and i found you know i produced a film
with marlon brando and i know his tricks
and what he used to do to directors and
i'd watch him do it and
he would give two takes that were almost
identical and see which one the director
liked better and if he knew the director
like the one he didn't really care about
then he he phoned it in he didn't care
and he he messed with directors and gary
messes with directors and dennis messed
with directors
and i i encourage new filmmakers to go
work with guys like that because
if you can cut your teeth on that it's
it's gonna you're gonna learn
you're gonna have seven years of film
school in one day with a guy like that
and what was really cool about gary is
the way he helped me develop the
character and work through the character
and what he demanded and commanded of me
as a filmmaker before we started he was
very involved in
working this out and making it happen
and then when he showed up on set
it was so neat i remember we did take
one and i remember i said
and cut and eternity goes notes
give me notes and i was like i got 25
people looking at me waiting for me to
go tell gary busey academy award winner
or academy award nominee golden globe
guy
you know tell him and i was scared to
death
and i walked up to him and i realized
what it was it was a show
and i just went up to i put my hands on
his elbows to see gary that was freaking
brilliant
i want to get it again will that make
you happy and he looked at me he goes
dude come on they're all looking at us
give me a goddamn note
alex i said a little bit more pause when
you go to sit down
before you give him that line that you
know and he goes
there we go and that was the only known
game all day just because he wanted a
note
and i was so out of my league at the
time and it's so out of out of the you
know
knowing how to deal with the moment and
he covered me but
he he he didn't need the note
he he showed up more prepared than
anybody and
just knocked it out of the park and did
exactly what i had hoped he would and we
had rehearsed it but
he tried to toughen me up and show me
that i need to be more vocal as a
filmmaker in front of people don't just
say
action cut that was great let's get it
again you know that was
it's about interacting and i learned so
much from that experience and you know
i've worked with some great actors you
know like jane seymour and
you know dennis hopper and and you know
good lord the list goes on and on
and um every one of those gives so much
to each project that we've done together
and i learn
so much but gary yeah gary gary was
baptism by fire he kicked my ass right
into gear
that was i knew once i once i wrapped on
busy
life got really easy it's amazing
why would an actor on that level of that
caliber
want to test someone they
it's about i think control it's about
how much
i am willing to give and i'm not it's
like i look at it as a relationship
if you're in a relationship with
somebody and you're
interested in taking that next level of
intimacy
you're going to put some feelers out to
see if this is somebody that you can
trust
and go that deep with emotionally and i
think actors like to try to break you
down some of them are just
flat out and like to control a
set and those are who they are and
gary was not that way at all what he
wanted to do is he wanted to see he
wanted to push my limits to see how much
he was willing to give back
and the reason he wanted to do the film
it's a funny story i sent the script to
his son jake to play a part
gary intercepted it called me and said
jake's not available he's in miami doing
a pilot for nbc
i read the script who's playing earl
cooper and i was like uh
uh and there was an actor kind of
attached and he goes well i want to play
it i've done 75 films and i've never
read a character
like this or been able to play this part
and i'd really like to play them
i mean i i sorry to kind of bogart the
script but i want to do it
he wasn't looking for a job he was busy
and i wasn't paying anything so it
wasn't like he was getting any money
so i went and met with him at his house
and we talked and just
the first time i sat with an actor of
that caliber and listened to him break
down
a script that i wrote and what he did is
he taught me the importance of what
happens off the page
you know he said look you you know shane
you've given me
you've given me page one to page 88
and i'm more interested about what's
before page one
and that's his story you know and gary
went into
this guy's childhood and what made him
who he is today and it
it really opened my mind as a
storyteller and as a writer and as a
director because now i understood how
actors thought
so it was an amazing experience that i
would work with gary 100 times over and
you know twice on sunday it was a great
experience
you